hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game uh between stockfish and chess
master it's a clash i wanted to to do
for quite some time now uh uh uh put the
old chess master from the nes uh system
from the old nintendo system from 1991
against the most powerful stockfish
stockfish 14 powered by uh neural
network powered by nnue which is
backwards for a efficiently updatable
neural network if you guys are
interested a bit more about why this is
so and why is stockfish integrated with
this i will put a link in the
description below if you guys uh are
interested you can read a little bit
more about it but basically it's an
extremely extremely uh strong um uh you
know uh playing engine
uh and uh it's uh well uh no one can
defeat it it's just the incredibly
strong sometimes leela beats it
sometimes uh uh stockfish n and ue beats
leela but basically it is um
for as long as it's been using neural
networks uh it's become uh like the the
strongest chess playing entity that we
have today even stronger than alpha zero
i imagine because alpha zero has been
out of commission for a very long time
uh if they powered it up again who knows
probably alpha zero because they have
such uh such strong
uh computers would would become more
powerful but for the moment uh this is
the uh
uh i i think as strong as as it gets so
how does it fare against the old chess
master from 1991 uh it was uh the the
chess master program was first published
in 1986 and it took some five years for
it to make its way over to the
nintendo entertainment system so i
imagine it was more powerful than back
in the days when it first was created
for the amiga or the atari or the apple
ii
or the commodore 64. so of course the
nes system had more power and it is a
bit faster but i still had to wait a
very very long time for the chess master
to make a move this is the
uh the one that i'm talking about let me
just load it up real quickly
uh it really uh does remind you of the
uh of the standard chess.com interface
this is the old chess master yeah there
you have it so this is this is how it
looked like uh
uh on on nintendo yeah in 1991 as you
can see uh the colors are very similar
to the to the standard theme of
chess.com so if you guys were wondering
about that but yeah uh stockfish pretty
much made the moves instantly i was
using it through the leeches interface
it also had cloud analysis so for the
first few moves um uh it had like depth
55 depth uh 56 so incredibly incredible
depth and
well that that could be an issue for the
old chess master but i always i i i mean
i had it as a kid i just um
of course i i wasn't really good at
chess i'm not really good at chess now
but i'm better than i was when i was
like six years old uh or rather what was
it in 1991 i was four yeah so yeah and i
didn't have a nintendo as soon as it
came out or the chess master probably
had it like maybe 93 94 or maybe even
later
it's hard to say but yeah probably
around when i was six so uh of course it
uh seemed unbeatable and
i mean i i didn't know anyone that could
come even close to beating it at the top
level so it could be quite a challenge
for
uh for stockfish uh or or maybe not
we'll see what happens so let's dive
straight into it and see how uh how it
did so stockfish opens with ponte e4 and
this is the move i made for stockfish
because for some reason stockfish always
wants to play at least this version of
stockfish always wants to go for daretti
and i didn't want to uh you know uh for
for it to be a already so first move for
stockfish was played by me and then uh
the two of them are battling it out so
here i just mastered replies with pawn
to e5 uh okay stalker goes knight to f3
and here we have knight to c6 we have
bishop to b5 uh the real opus is on the
board and a6 chess master goes for the
uh for the morphy's defense and now
before we continue the game uh this is
the same chess master that you guys
probably remember you've had it maybe
you've had chess master one maybe chess
master two maybe five maybe seven maybe
maybe nine maybe chess master grand
masters edition that i um
often like to to remind people about
because you have uh incredibly
incredible lessons by the legendary josh
waitskin there if you guys can uh you
know get your hands on that piece of
software the chess master grand master
edition uh it is one of the finer
academies i have ever seen uh
specifically due to the
josh wade skin academy so if you can get
that i mean you will not be sorry uh so
but uh yeah let's get back to the game
and we have bishop to a4 and now knight
to f6 uh just continuing with the
columbus variation castles and the
bishop the e7 and uh also there is a
there is an option in the chess master
uh
the the old one from the nintendo
entertainment system uh do you want to
turn on deep thinking and i was like
what is deep thinking on on chess master
from 1991 and then i read the manual and
it's basically uh do you want chess
master to think about the position while
it's your move and you could allow him
this and you could uh
prevent him from doing this so i allowed
this uh but it was pretty pointless that
stockfish was making moves uh pretty
much instantly
so here rook to e1 and this is still the
opening uh we have b5 challenging the
bishop bishop to b3 and now pawn to d6
we have c3 by stockfish uh and now comes
castles we have pawn to a4 and now this
is where the game gets really really
interesting so here nowadays uh
you you can play b4 or you can play
bishop to d7 or even bishop to g4 so
it's very interesting that chess master
chooses this option bishop to g4 we have
h3 challenging the bishop and this is
where chess master really does a weird
move here basically what you want to do
is bishop captures an f3 bishop to h5 or
bishop to d7 but here uh chess master
played b captures on a4 and
i don't know if it loses the game on the
spot but it makes black's position very
very very uh hard to handle so that this
was not played by anyone and it is not
as a move tender we have a completely
new game so here bishop captures on a4
attacks the knight and the bishop here
and now just the bishop captures an f3
chess master grabs the knight on f3
queen captures on f3 still you have to
do something about this knight and now
knight to a5 not going for knight to b8
as that would be
uh well just putting the knight back
where it came from but now stockfish
plays the all-powerful move that i know
you guys are looking at as that move
pretty much always wins the game and
that is pawn to b4
we have knight to c4 and now comes
bishop the c6 attacking the rook so how
do you defend here of course uh rook to
b8 and now comes pawn to d3 challenging
this night and here
uh
you don't really have a good reply with
the knight you could go knight back to
b6 for example knight b6 rook captures
on a6 but if you look at this position
you can see that black's position is
completely paralyzed this bishop here is
such a good uh attacking piece i mean it
just completely
uh stifles the entire position the rook
just grabbed the pawn also the rook can
come to a7 it's um i mean it's it's just
a beautiful beautiful position the
knight can come over to a3 to c4 to b5
uh there's really no good move for black
uh to make here so it's a very
interesting that uh chess master instead
of uh going for a passive position like
this instead chooses to give up a piece
rook to b6 display now attacking the
bishop but stockfish just moves it back
bishop to a4 and now there is no way for
you to save the knight as all of your
escape squares are covered there there
there's no way to save the knight so
chess master goes ahead and starts
attacking with
d5 uh stalkfish grabs the piece d
captures on c4 d captures an e4 and now
queen to e3 so stockfish up a piece
chess master has some
some development in stockfish still has
to develop most of the pieces and if
chess master can get some sort of an
attack going maybe not h5 maybe the
knight comes to f4 maybe the rook is
shifted over to g6 who knows what might
happen but here we have queen to a8 now
putting another defender to the to the
pawn here uh and now pawn to c5 grabbing
more space um making the dark square
bishop useful and forcing the rook to
move back rook b to b8 and now bishop
back to c2 now uh the knight is coming
to d2 and then of course stockfish is
planning to capture on e4 and chess
master is basically helpless against
this plan we have rook f to d8 now comes
knight to d2 and now uh knight to d5
going after the queen here but it
doesn't help still uh here queen
captures an e4 is played now threatening
queen captures an h7 and here when i got
to this position it took uh quite a long
time for for chess master to make the
moves uh somewhere incredibly long for
some it took like 20 minutes but here
chess master simply refused to make a
move and uh for good reason there's
really no good move you can make you you
have to move the knight back to stop
checkmate then uh the queen will move
and the game continues but there is
nothing for for black to look forward to
here black is just down a piece and
stockfish will very very easily win this
so instead uh knight captures and c3 was
played
allowing checkmate in two but there is
an option in chess master there is a
an option where you can force chess
master to make a move and here i clicked
that as it was taking a ridiculous
amount of time for you know chess master
to admit that he's just worse so i
thought that he was just going to move
the knight back or something but he
actually played knight captures on c3
and stockfish delivered a nice checkmate
here uh queen captures an h7 king to f8
and queen to h8 with checkmate so it's a
fairly quick game 24 moves and this was
chess master the old chess master on the
highest level uh but um
like i said uh uh on this occasion uh
it it just didn't go chess masters way
already in the opening here after h3 was
played uh it decided to go out of books
so neither of um
the moves were played that are actually
good here for black but b characters on
a4 that is sort of uh playable but not
really after
after a few more sub-optimal moves
stockfish immediately gained the the
winning advantage and it just completely
crushed chess master
uh so yeah i always wondered how this
matchup would turn out of course it's
not a it's not a fair matchup but i uh
always always i kind of thought chess
master was stronger than this but
apparently not uh as i've read in the
manual that they've rated it in the
beginning uh they rated it like it was
already 2000 and then maybe maybe like
maybe more than 2 000 but it was very
hard to make making an exact evaluation
of the program
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it if you have any other
chess entities that you would like me to
test against each other especially from
from different uh decades like these two
uh do um uh do sharing the comments and
i will look into uh into you know uh
making a brawl out of it
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
kathleen altia cash man robert arthur uh
cold feet reckless pawn and ravishing
reptiles youtube for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day